Yeah.
In Martin Luther King would be the
number one person.
Um,
it's just so amazing that guy,
you know,
and I wish he was alive today,
uh,
because I won't again to his head and
just find out what he was thinking when
he said things.
So when he,
you know,
went to,
uh,
to lead them,
a protest or what have you.
So,
uh,
he was such an amazing guy and a,
you know,
I think he's influenced my life a lot,
then he will be the number one person I
want to talk with,
you know,
um,
I,
I love Mandela or also,
um,
hey,
these are just incredible guys that come
once in a while,
you know,
uh,
maybe Obama would be the next one,
so we'll see.
But,
uh,
you know,
you don't get a lot of these people,
who you can look up to as mentors,
you know,
um,
uh,
you know,
two great icons like that.
And,
and unfortunately some of these big icon
stays always tragedies surrounding them.
You know,
and I am not,
I've never been able to,
to understand why must you have a
tragedy for someone to be such a great
icon,
you know?
But yeah.
Ah.